elle est avec nous tasha kheiriddin
stratège conservatrice communicatrice
autrice et ancienne collaboratrice du
téléjournal il faut le dire bon sens à
chaque soir c'est merci beaucoup et de
m'accueillir oui il faut aussi préciser
que vous êtes là coprésident de la
campagne de jean charest dans cette
course à la chefferie donc tasha dans
votre livre vous vous parlez d'un parti
qui est très divisée donc entre les
populistes et les pragmatistes sont
peut-être les conservateurs plus modérée
dans vous faites partie mais quand on
regarde la course en ce moment on est à
trois semaines là on va savoir dans
trois semaines le gagnant sont vraiment
les populistes qui sont en train de
l'emporter je pense que le populisme
c'est un courant qui est là depuis très
longtemps dans le parti ou le mouvement
conservateur ça fait plus de cent ans ça
va et ça vient on a vu le parti
réformiste et oui il ya une vague
populiste on peut pas la nier qui est
présentement en train de balayer les
conservateurs est ce que ça veut dire
que c'est les jeux sont faits pour jean
charest non je pense pas du tout je
pense que ça ce que ça veut dire c'est
un mouvement vraiment qu'on voit dans
d'autres pays qui est arrivé ici ça
alimente une certaine c'est sûr il ya
certains candidats monsieur paul élèves
qui bénéficient de ce courant là mais le
courant je dirais ce n'est pas le pays
entier qui est balayé et c'est pour ça
que les conservateurs doivent se méfier
du populisme parce que c'est sûr qu'il
ya des gens qui s'attache à ça à cause
des deux lacs au vide des restreint qui
ont été imposées ils se sentent qu'ils
ont bloquée peut-être aussi par les
élites comme ils disent mais ce qu'on
voit aussi qu'il ya beaucoup de
consommateurs plus centriste ou des gens
qui se sont pas considérés politiquement
engagé mais qui sont plus modérées mais
de droite qui seraient prêts à voter
conservateur mais le populisme c'est pas
quelque chose auquel ils s'attachent
alors pour le parti conservateur il doit
vraiment peser les jeux vous quel
message de ce qu'ils veulent véhiculer
après cette course qu elle quand elle
est finie je remarque que vous n'avez
pas répondu donc est ce que les jeux
sont faits aujourd'hui s'en passer non
ne vous ont pas fait parce que les
balles les bulletins de vote ne sont pas
tous remis on s'attend pas qu'ils sont
tous remis non plus c'est pas tout le
monde qui va voter dans cette course là
si à cinquante pour cent des gens qui
remettent leur bulletin c'est
probablement ce qu'on va voir
et c'est une course sur le terrain alors
tout le monde sort monsieur charest
comme tous et sur le terrain en train de
sortir le vote et c'est ça qui va
compter les machines électorales divers
candidats alors c'est cette puissance
l'acquis qui va jouer à la fin de la
journée pourtant quand on regarde un peu
les derniers sondages on se rend compte
qu ait pas beaucoup d'appétit pour un
parti dirigé par un conservateur plus
modérés comme monsieur charest je dirais
que non dans le reste du pays on voit
aussi dans les gens qui ne sont pas des
consommateurs des membres conservateurs
que messieurs charest dans plusieurs
sondages auraient un meilleur score que
monsieur paul hier mais c'est pas ça du
livre que je traîne dans les lits
vraiment le livre l'idée c'est vraiment
de démontrer que ces deux courants la
représente deux voies très différent
pour le parti et n'importe qui qui
devient devient le chef doit se méfier
des choses néfastes qui peuvent
s'attacher au populisme tandis que le
fait que le conservatisme si on le
retrouve dans son état pu vraiment qui
est une vision de responsabilité et de
liberté mais en même temps de
responsabilité de devoir à la communauté
et à la société en général que si ça
vraiment et plus expliqué je pense aux
gens qu'il ya plus de gens qui se sont
ralliés au populisme qui aussi
pourraient se rallier à cette vision là
je pense qu'on va rattraper plus de gens
au centre droite aussi avec quelque
chose de ce genre parce que c'est très
risqué en fait ce que c'est ce que vous
dites dans votre livre pour les
conservateurs de dalé de d'aller dans
cette voie un peu con qu'on croyait un
peu réservé aux états unis on se disait
est ce que ça va arriver au canada ben
oui c'est arrivé c'est quelque chose qui
est arrivé plus tard ici qu aux
etats-unis et que dans le reste du monde
et c'est vraiment je pense là que vit
depuis à accélérer ce processus là mais
l'aco vide n'est pas à jamais non plus
et c'est pour ça aussi il faut se méfier
parce que toutes les restrictions qui
sont en train de tomber
les gens qui ont été alimentées par ceux
là est ce qu'ils vont être là pour
travailler dans une élection à ce qu'ils
vont se rattacher à un parti ou est ce
que c'est juste une colère qui s'exprime
qui est tous temporaires et les études
démontrent que parfois le populisme
c'est des vagues ça va et ça vient mais
des principes conservateurs éternelle
c'est quelque chose qui est là depuis
plus de 100 ans pour le parti dans
diverses formes au canada alors c'est
pour ça que je dis que c'est quelque
chose un peu plus solide sur quoi on
peut se baser et on le remarque éric
duhaime ici en a fait son slogan
l'hébreu chez nous pierre poilievre
parle beaucoup de liberté les
camionneurs aussi qu'est ce qui attire
tellement qu est ce qu il ya dans ce mot
si porteur parmi les partisans mais
c'est porteur et c'est pas porter parmi
certains partisans absolument et j'ai
parlé à des centaines de conservateurs
en écrivant ce livre il ya des jeunes
par exemple qui sont présents emballé
par le sentiment de la liberté il ya des
gens qui ont perdu leur liberté pour
opérer leur commerce ou avant la fin
débit eux aussi se sentent ils veulent
être libres à vivre leur vie faire ces
choix là mais à d'autres mondes aussi
qui disent ça les effraye ce mot là
parce que ça perdu le sens qu'ils
avaient ce n'est plus simplement la
liberté comme on le comprenait c'est la
liberté de faire ce qu'on veut en dépit
de l'effet sur nos voisins sur l'autre
hui et c'est pas ça qui est cherché non
plus aux états unis où c'est ça a été
attachée à des extrémistes aussi c'est
très malheureux parce que la liberté est
un principe conservateur mais il faut le
comprendre en compagnie avec la
responsabilité et moi je dit que
vraiment le mot qui regroupe tout le
monde c'est l'opportunité parce que ce
que tout le monde cherche c'est pas
juste la liberté de faire n'importe quoi
c'est l'opportunité de racheter une
maison qu'on veut ou avoir le travail
qu'on veut ou avoir une meilleure vie
pour nos enfants l'opportunité est
l'égalité d'opportunités c'est à quoi je
pense le parti devrait s'accrocher
pensez pas que c'est un message qui
arrive un peu tard en tout cas dans
cette course là elle arrive en pige
arrive un peu tard non je ne pense pas
parce que je pense que les gens reflète
depuis longtemps la course ça fait quoi
presque six mois qu'elle est là les gens
où il a chance de réfléter à tout ça a
parlé aux candidats je pense qu'ils vont
faire un choix éclairé et comme j'ai dit
n'importe quoi qui arrive après le 10
septembre les élections j'espère en tout
cas vont pas tomber le lendemain mais ça
va donner le parti aussi le temps de se
regrouper pour la prochaine élection et
décider quel courant il va prendre
dirigé au moins un député qui a annoncé
qu'ils seraient qu'il ne serait pas là
si ce monsieur pop au lièvre est élu
vous qu'est ce que vous allez faire le
10 septembre monsieur poilievre était
lui un mois je vais regarder ce qui se
passe je vais militer pour le parti
parce que c'est ce que je fais et je
vais voir ce que le chef va faire et ce
chef d'apporter qui que ce soit a le
gros défi de garder le parti ensemble
c'est ça le premier défi et doit tendre
la main à ceux qui n'étaient pas dans
son camp alors c'est ça que je pense que
tous les conservateurs y compris moi
vous regardez qu'est ce que 7 mai va
être tendu qu'est ce qui va être les
efforts pour garder la famille ensemble
et c'est ce qui va déterminer le succès
à la prochaine élection parce que pour
garder tout le monde ensemble pour
travailler ce sera pas un troisième
partie qui pourrait créer comme vous
l'évoquez dans votre livre je dis que
c'est ce qu'on craint mais on devrait
pas le faire parce que si on le fait on
va scinder le vote ce que le parti
réformiste avait fait ce que le parti de
créditiste avait fait 2 j champ libre
aux libéraux exactement 13 ans de
libéraux encore non merci c'est ce qu'on
a vécu dans les années 93 alors on
suivra tout s'attache à carrer del merci
beaucoup d'être passé pour nous parler
de votre lui merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup c'est bien ça me fait plaisir